like thank you for being here today
I'm delighted at the chance to have this
conversation I have a few questions here
on your professional journey your
leadership philosophy in your personal
life before we open it up to questions
from audience and Twitter as dean
saloner mentioned you've been incredibly
generous with your time at the GSB this
is the fourth view from the top session
that you are a part of which must be
some fall for record since the last time
you were here we knew from the top which
was in 2011 the big decision that you
made was to become the CEO of HP this
was not an easy job in fact this is what
Falls magazine had to say about it
Meg stepped into a mess HP stock had
tumbled 42 percent in the year before
archrival Dell was gaining ground and HP
seemed powerless to stop it HP had
squeezed out its four previous CEOs
Whitman's immediate predecessor in
lasted just 11 months what made you
decide to take on the role and I said a
good question
so I answer as Garth had mentioned I
have lost the race for governor and one
of the things that's interesting when
you lose a political race unlike
anything else you do the day you lose
the next day you have nothing to do no
meetings nothing you're sitting alone
and none of your friends call you
because they feel so badly for you and
so it was February and I was trying to
figure out what I was going to do next
and it was one afternoon I was sitting
at home and my husband has a
neurosurgeon here at Stanford Kim into
the living room or into our family room
at 4 o'clock he got home early and I was
sitting there watching Ellen DeGeneres
looked at me and goes oh this is really
not good it's sort of fairly not good
and like as if on cue the next day Marc
Andreessen called to see if I'd like to
sit on the board of HP and I thought
fabulous this is great what what could
go wrong 12 minutes from my house
incredibly while we're on company you
know I'll be on the committee it'll be
great fun well of course you know nine
months later the company was in a big
challenge
and at first I said no but was
ultimately persuaded by the fact that
companies like HP matter in my view they
mattered to Silicon Valley I would argue
they matter to California they matter to
the United States and frankly they
matter globally we are an incredibly
important corporate citizen across the
world in other for example were the
second largest private employer in Costa
Rica I think with the third largest
private employer in the Czech Republic
so it matters what happens to this
company and I thought you know what
maybe I can make a small contribution to
reviving HP and its place in Silicon
Valley and in the tech world so
ultimately decided to take it on and in
some ways the probably the biggest
advantage I had was I was not a Freshman
CEO had I been a freshman CEO I think I
might have been completely overwhelmed
by what happened here but the good news
is I've been a CEO for 10 years I kind
of knew how things worked I understood
how Wall Street worked and I think was
you know more effective than I would
have otherwise been if this was my first
rodeo and you've spoken about
understanding what is going on right
within an organization as you join it
yes what was going right at HP what had
to be fixed so I think this is a very
good lesson for all of you when you find
yourself in a new situation particularly
in a senior leadership role and you're
in a new organization your instinct is
to go fix what's wrong right make the
list of all the things that need to be
fixed and go after them my advice now
having done this on a number of times is
go into an organization and figure out
what that company's doing right and do
more of it you'll eventually get to your
to-do-list
into your fix-it list but if you come in
and just talk about what's growing wrong
you will lose hearts and minds so to
your point I figured out immediately
what the founder DNA was of HP and
despite all the acquisitions all the
board drama everything that had happened
to this company the founder DNA from
Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard had shown
through and first of all it's an
engineering innovation company that's
who this company is and second we're
partnering company the DNA of this
company is very collaborative we sell
for 150,000 VARs and so actually
focusing back on collaboration on our
channel partners was part of the success
of the turnaround and then finally to my
surprise this company cares a lot about
social responsibility and this was bill
a Dave were all about the environment
we're all about giving back to
communities before this was even
remotely fashionable there was no term
called social responsibility but it's
interesting you can see it around the
globe with HP people so we just went
back to those three things innovation
innovation innovation we focused it we
increased our D and we let the engineers
do their work and we pivoted hard back
to partners so what had to be fixed so
there were a number of things that had
to be fixed first of all we have to win
hearts and minds of HP people because
you mentioned did four CEOs in the
previous five years or six years and I
will say that the workforce was
reasonably jaded as you would be my
first All Hands meeting we survey
everyone at HP on everything all the
time I think we're like Survey monkeys
largest customer and the first survey
was you know how do you think about the
new CEO and the number one response was
she seems nice dot dot dot
meaning like how long is this one going
to last and what is she going to do so
we had to win hearts and minds of people
and get them back on the boat and
believing again in the future of HP so
that was job number one number two is we
had to align our cost structure with our
revenue trajectory revenues were falling
at sort of eight to ten percent and you
cannot you cannot let that happen
without making a pretty significant
change to the fundamental cost structure
of the company and then third is we
weren't keeping up with innovation and
so we had to actually focus innovation
get HP Labs in gear again and attract
talent and promote talent from within
who could take us to the new you know to
a new place from an innovation
perspective so whether that was cloud or
security or big data or the next
generation of infrastructure or our next
generation of services we had to we had
to go about fixing this right away and
frankly we had to unfreeze the frozen
middle you know the challenge when you
come into these companies is you
can usually get your senior executives
you either replace them or they get
onboard the the early folks young career
they're all over it they're like okay
this is what we want to do it's what we
call the frozen middle that you have to
go figure out how you get them on board
with the agenda that you're trying to
achieve so those were some of the things
then we had a few issues like the EDS
write down the autonomy situation you
know there was like a hundred sort of
relatively I would say neither of those
were minor problems but they were sort
of tactical problems that had to be
dealt with along with the strategic
challenge of who was this company
because you might remember right before
I took over the previous CEO had said
maybe kinda-sorta we were thinking about
spinning the PC business so of course
that led everyone in our community of
buyers to ask the question what is HP
strategy so that's the other thing we
had to sort out in the first couple of
months and then how did you go about
doing some of these things so it was
pretty challenging because many of you
know my background in technology is more
in consumer technology than it is in
enterprise technology and HP for the
most part is an enterprise company even
our printing and PC business 2/3 of our
printers and PCs are sold to business as
opposed to consumers and so I had to
learn the technology business from an
enterprise perspective I needed to learn
what we did I needed to get my arms
around this vast company and so I tried
a number of things first is you know
assembled a sort of a group of people
who I thought could help then I brought
some people in from the outside who
understood the industry like Scott
McNealy then I sort of said ok well
that's interesting now maybe I need some
external consulting help and it was
really a process over a couple year
period to figure out what this company
did well and then how to achieve the
objectives and of course the ultimate
decision lay in creating this separation
of two companies I think most of you
know we are separating Hill and Packard
into two fortune 50 companies can you
imagine there were two fortune 50
companies embedded in HP HP Inc which
will be our printer and personal
systems business is a fifty seven
billion dollar business and Hill at
Packard Enterprise which is our data
center business our server storage
networking converged infrastructure
cloud security software as well as our
enterprise services business is also a
fifty seven billion dollar company so
that freeing of to be more focused to
have a capital structure that is right
for the market opportunities that both
these companies face is going to be a
big enabler of the two strategies that
we've now crafted for HP Inc and he'll
at Packard Enterprise so it's completely
the right thing to do but by the way
took a fair amount of courage to
actually make that decision because
there are the law of unintended
consequences as you can imagine but we
feel really good about it and so the
separation occurs November 1st so knock
on wood well guess it all separated just
going back a bit the last time we were
here you spoke about how early on
perhaps you were not fully convinced
about the ebay opportunity yeah
what got you convinced that you had on
your hands of inner yeah so I think many
people know the story so I was at Hasbro
running the preschool division which was
Barney Arthur Teletubbies my personal
favorite mr. Potato Head and minding my
own business my husband was running the
brain tumor program at Harvard's
Teaching Hospital the Mass General which
in the medical world is everyone sort of
aspires to the Mass General
the MGH the acronym is they'd like to
say man's greatest hospital I would
argue that there might be another one
out on the west coast but in any case
and I got a call from a headhunter about
joining this no name Internet company
called eBay and I said no I'm not moving
my husband and two boys 3,000 miles
across the company we're not doing this
and he called back three weeks later and
he said Meg I'm begging you to come meet
with the founder and I didn't want to
make the headhunter mad I thought I
certainly do not want this job but I
might want his next job and so I will
put myself on a plane and so I came out
and spent the day with Pierre Omidyar
and Jeff Skoll and at the end of the day
I called my husband from San Francisco
Airport and I said hon we should do this
the reason was what I saw in my long
years in the consumer space if you can
see two things in a company then you
have liftoff number one is does that
consumer product or service enable you
to do something you could not do before
in a real and meaningful way so in my
program build a is white or white you
know fresher breath cleaner teeth in a
meaningful way but what I saw at eBay
was it enabled people to make
connections and to trade without regard
to time and distance so for example if
you used to be a collector of civil war
memorabilia you could only do that in
your town all of a sudden you could
collect across the country and across
the globe
it made an inefficient market efficient
and there was price discovery through
the auction format so that's one thing
so I saw right away real meaningful
things you could not do before and then
I figured out people had made personal
connections they had an affinity for
eBay people had met their best friends
on eBay they had connected over a shared
area of interest
you could argue eBay was the first
social networking company because there
was a deep connection over a shared area
of interest and collectors were the
first to come to eBay and collectors
when you have a passion for something
like glass or teapots or Barbies or
whatever happens to me people think
you're a little weird right
you know not everyone understands a
passion for teacups but when you find
other people who love teacups then you
have this incredible connection and so I
saw real features and functionality and
an emotional connection to the company
and I said to my husband I said this
thing is going to be big I never dreamed
it would be as big as it was but I said
this is what you look for in a career in
consumer products and services a lot of
us in the audience are moving from sort
of non technology backgrounds into
leadership positions and technology not
unlike how you yeah has been into eBay
but not a lot of experience in
technology businesses what advice would
you have for us who try to do that
so I think a couple things one is
business principles apply regardless of
the industry you know I spend a fair
amount of time with my CEO colleagues
and we laugh because business is
business honestly whether you are at
Procter & Gamble at Twitter at HP at you
know Wells Fargo Bank at caterpillar
Tractor the principles are exactly the
same what I will say in technology you
need to be either end up as a deep
technologist or you need to surround
yourself with deep technologists because
there is an element of being able to see
around corners to be able to see what is
next and so if you are not from a
technology background and you're not an
engineer you need to find the people in
your organization who will help you plot
the technology path and the technology
vision and so that's probably the advice
and then you've just got to ask the
questions you know you cannot be
embarrassed to ask question about
something and and by the way the
technologists will see what you're made
of they will they will try to to sort of
ferret you out as a pretender and so
better not to be a pretender would be my
advice I'll tell you a little story so
there was the CI the CTO at eBay a
really very talented guy named Mike
Wilson who had written the second
version of eBay who was Skippy on the
boards at night was sort of the
Community Builder and he was not
entirely he was actually enthusiastic
when I came but you might recall we had
a very severe outage and eBay in June
10th at 5 o'clock in 1999 I remember
like it was yesterday
anyway early on in my career before that
at eBay um I was trying to figure out
how much because we had outages all the
time and I was trying to figure out how
much capacity we had in the system and
Mike didn't think about the question
that way and didn't really want to
answer the question in the way I was
asking because I was saying I said I
reverted to my shoe company experience I
said ok if we had a shoe factory in
South Korea the people could tell me
exactly how many pairs of shoes we could
get through this factory because well I
don't think about it that way so we had
sort of this little tussle
then I get an email not too many days
later that starts off by the title of
the emails cookies meg is probably
wondering if we're a baking company well
okay I was like fit to be tied and and
so that's where you actually have to
take a stand you know and so it was one
of those sort of seminal moments in you
know where you have to basically push
back and and lead regardless of what
they're you know what the sort of the
entrenched interests are trying to do
and to Pierre Omidyar credit he was a
defender all the way through that and so
it also helps if you've got a founder
technologist who is actually helping to
remove this company into it into a new
area right leading up to eBay is grad
school PG Bain & Company
yes nian Hasbro as we think about our
phones jobs out of school what advice do
you have for us yeah so listen I think
it's a little different graduating from
Business School today than it was in
1979 when I graduated from business
school does it seem like a hundred years
ago um first of all there was not the
startup culture that there is today in
Silicon Valley and in Austin Texas and
in Boston Massachusetts I mean I don't
think anyone really seriously considered
starting their own company out of
Harvard Business School or joining a
start-up it just wasn't what you did it
wasn't really in the menu of things and
I think many of you will join a startup
or start a company so back then what we
were thinking was how do we get the very
best training for a long career in
business how do we like lay the pipe of
things that we will need to know through
a career and so that's why I chose to go
to I was interested in marketing so I
decided to go to what I perceived as the
very best company in marketing and that
was P&G because you have to remember I
had no work experience between
undergraduate and graduate school so I
was all about the training and I have to
say you know it's it's really quite fun
because I now sit on the P&G board you
know talk about coming full circle but
what I learned at P&G has stood me in
good stead till this day so I was all
about going to the best companies to get
the best training to prepare for what I
believed would be a long career you know
today if I was doing it I don't
know what I would do I have to say my 9
years of bein with some of the best
experience I've ever had you know
just learned everything about you know
cost competition competitors you know
strategy I mean again everything that I
learned at Bain those nine years I have
I employed deployed at eBay and also
frankly at HP because we had to figure
out what our strategy was so you know I
think you have to sort of live in the
times in which you graduate it's a very
different environment than it was and
you know listen it's hard to it's hard
to know exactly what I did today because
I don't see the I mean I see the
opportunities that you have but it's
that balance between showing up at a
startup versus getting a little bit more
laying a pipe that's going to sit set
you up in good stead but the great thing
about it is today is there's no harm no
foul okay so you graduate from business
school you join a startup and it doesn't
work it's inconvenient but it's not the
end of your life
and you know when I joined eBay you know
I said look what's the worst thing that
can happen it doesn't work out and then
I don't get another job so you know I
think you have to have the appropriate
level of risk-taking for your personal
situation for your personality and for
what the opportunities are this might be
a good opportunity to perhaps pivot and
talk a bit about your leadership
philosophy do you have the reputation of
someone who goes by the maxim run to the
fire
yeah don't hide from it yes what were
the key factors when you were growing up
that contributed to who you are today so
you mean like K through 12 kind of
growing up pretty much so listen I was
probably that generation of women who
was really at the at the beginning edge
of women going to business school and
frankly to law school and to medical
school yes there were precursors to me
but we were the first generation that
that sort of arrived in real numbers and
but real numbers is a relative thing my
first year class at Procter & Gamble had
a hundred brand assistants of which four
were women and so my mother I think was
very instrumental in convincing my
sister and I
and frankly my brother that we could
actually do anything that we set our
minds to and I'll tell you a little
story some of you may have heard it so
my mother during World War two really
wanted to you know help with the war
effort but there weren't just a ton of
opportunities for women so she decided
to join the Red Cross and they said this
class of women we're going to deploy you
to the you know the the Pacific to New
Guinea and so she got on a troop ship
from San Francisco to New Guinea with
like a thousand women on a troop ship
they get to New Guinea and the base
commander greets this group of women and
says hey we have a shortage of airplane
mechanics and truck mechanics which of
you would like to volunteer okay my
mother had never looked under the hood
of anything I promise you and but she
sort of looked abandoned well seems like
this is where the need is greatest and
so she raised her hand and the long and
short of this is four years later she
was a fully certified airplane mechanic
and a fully certified truck mechanic and
she brought that to us as kids she said
listen if I can figure out how to be an
airplane mechanic you can do anything
you want to do so I think it was that
sort of encouragement and then I I have
to say team sports was a really
formative experience for me I played
team sports from the time I was a little
girl
right through college and it was
incredibly formative in terms of I think
how I lead so the courage to take on
anything was born very early and one
would argue that that courage is a
really important character I think in
business you also have to be smart about
it one could argue that the courage to
run for governor was not Pro the most
informed said of courage so you have to
be you have to be careful but I think
risk-taking was born early on I mean
going to HP was a risk running for
governor was a risk frankly going to
ebay was a risk some of them worked out
one of them didn't let's let's talk
about that a bit yeah what led you do um
what led you into politics and what did
you learn when you didn't win yeah so
let's see how much time do we have
mom so what let me was that I'd always
been interested in politics and had had
a chance to work on
my friend Mitt Romney's campaign so my
boss had been in company for ten years
was mitt and I guess he's coming here in
three or four weeks um so I had watched
him run for Senator run for governor and
then ultimately run for president and
then what he lost the first race for
president city I'd been quite involved
with his campaign and I signed on to
John McCain's campaign as a business
person and so I'd been interested in
politics and then I saw what challenges
this state faced it's hard to remember
but in 2010 we had about a hundred and
sixty eight billion dollar budget
deficit the school system had degraded
here dramatically still hat still is so
in 1956 the public school system in
California was number one rated in the
country it's now number 49 out of 50
states all kinds of challenges around
water that we see today it was
completely clear in 2010 that we had to
take action around the infrastructure in
water and so I thought given my business
background given sort of the
problem-solving nature of what we're all
trained to do I actually thought that I
could potentially be an example of the
citizen democracy which is you go do
something and then go into business go
into politics and maybe go back so
that's why I decided to do it and what
did I learn okay lesson number one is
you should probably not run as a
Republican in a state that is largely
democratic okay you actually need to do
the math and then believe the mass so
that was sort of one problem for those
of you who are outside of California
it's basically 60% Democrat 40%
Republican there's a huge chunk of
independence but the independents lean
one way or the other so you sort of
start with a challenge and then
secondarily there is something to be
said for people who have spent their
career in politics I'm not arguing it's
the right thing but just like I have
spent my career in business and
instinctively I know things by breathing
because I've done it for so long when
you were in politics there is instincts
about that and I didn't have any of
those instincts because I had never done
it before and so I think it's just
important to recognize that experience
does matter here and have you noticed
the politicians rarely answer directly
the question that they are as
it is not because they're bad people
it's not because they don't know the
answer to the question it's because
there is no percentage in answering
those questions because one way or
another you're either gaining or losing
votes and so there is a reason the
politicians act the way they do as
citizens it sort of drives us crazy
I made some cardinal errors which I
actually answered the question and so
listen it was a terrific experience it
made me much tougher I have a very thick
skin for the press you know when I came
to HP this is a great story there was a
fair amount of criticism about me coming
to HP in fact there was one headline
that I remember which is Silicon Valley
is howling with laughter that meg is the
CEO of HP and the board who had asked me
to do this was we had a board meeting
that first day and so they're reading
all this press and they're feeling a
little bit badly for me and I'm reading
the press and I said okay do not feel
bad because this is the best press I
have had in two-and-a-half years so it's
all kind of relevant and it's all kind
of you know relevant to what your frame
of references and I will say we should
be very grateful to people who run for
office because it is the hardest thing I
have ever done it is a hundred times
harder than running HP on our worst days
running for governor was much much more
difficult so we should all celebrate our
colleagues and people who are willing to
put themselves forward because there is
nothing like having your name on the
ballot you can't actually imagine it
until you do it it's a lot a lot of
really really good learnings thank you
and sitting back of it how did you think
about building a personal brand
throughout your carrier was that the
conscious crafting process or it just
happened by being authentic to who you
are how's that work yeah you know I
didn't think a lot about this I'm not
sure when I graduated from business
school there was this notion of a
personal brand I just kind of went in
and did the job that I was asked to do
and I think I made a couple of decisions
early which is an epi ng one of my first
assignments when I arrived as a newly
minted Harvard MBA was
got how big the hole in the shampoo cap
should be well and I'm thinking okay
this is a shampoo company don't they
have people who do this and this cannot
be the first time that they are
encountering this question and I almost
went to my brand manager and said okay
this is like a really stupid assignment
and how about we just skip the
formalities here and we get into
something that is meeting I went home
that night and decided better of it and
I actually flipped over I said okay I'm
gonna do the very best job that has ever
been done figuring out how big the hole
in the shampoo counter should be I did
focus groups I did quantitative testing
and I wrote the best memo that has ever
been written on this particular subject
and what it taught me was that sometimes
you just need to buckle down and do what
you are being asked to do particularly
early on in your career even though it
seems idiotic and what was really going
on here is PMG was trying to teach us
how to get things done at P&G
right they did actually know the answer
to the question but they were trying to
teach you about how things got done
about how to write memos about how
quantitative analysis actually did yield
I mean a lot of business problems do
yield to analysis so I think the
personal brand was perhaps just you know
actually doing the very best job I knew
how to do in it in overtime a reasonably
authentic way because you are you guys
are all who you are you know you will
grow and you will change over the next
decade or two but fundamentally you are
who you are and you have to double down
on those strengths there's a lot of
consulting firms will say how do you
shore up what is real weaknesses my view
is you do have to have some competency
and things that are not your core but
actually what is your zone of genius
what do you do really really well and
often that is what you like to do and so
actually sort of that authentic knowing
what you love to do knowing what you're
good at I would say was it wasn't part
of my personal brand because I didn't
think about it that way but that's
actually in some ways what I fell into a
lot more personal questions later
you were married to array successful
neurosurgeon you moved to Boston with
your husband when he accepted the
position in Massachusetts General
later in your family move to California
when you became the CEO of eBay how do
you balance two successful careers in a
family yeah so actually with lots of
challenges this has really been
interesting and quite a bit of fun but I
will say in some ways it would have been
easy if I had been married to a sculptor
because that would have been a little
bit more flexible and actually my
husband and I laugh with each other
because no sooner did one of us get
traction at a job than the other one
would have a brilliant idea about what
they wanted to do and we used to say we
spent much of the first 25 years of
being married sabotaging each other's
careers and so for example I was at
Disney and I loved every minute of my
four years at Disney I might still be at
Disney but at that time my husband got a
chance to run the brain tumor center at
Mass General and he really wanted to do
it and I really did not want to do it
but sometimes in life you have to do
things that you do not want to do so we
picked up and moved back to Boston and
you know you just kind of go with it and
I have to give him credit because when I
got the job at eBay I was pretty
convinced that this is something that we
should do but it was not obvious and so
I so he said I know why don't you go out
and see how it goes for six months I'm
like no no no no no no we're not doing
that actually I need you to see if you
can find a job so he called up - the
good news is there's only 3,000
neurosurgeons in the whole country so
they actually know each other so he
called up Gary Steinberg who runs
neurosurgery here at Stanford and a
colleague up at UCSF and I know how this
conversation went with Gary Steinberg
which was my wife wants to go to this
no-name Internet company you don't have
a job do you any and this is where fate
comes in what Gary said is you know what
I'm opening a search for the head of the
brain tumor program today you can have
it if you will so it never actually
happens that way
so it's a little bit of luck and a
little bit of courage and to my
husband's credit we had at that time we
had saved up about four hundred thousand
dollars and what I did is actually took
that money and invested it I actually
bought my options out Eddie day and I
said to Griff doesn't it seem like a
little risky he goes listen we have much
bigger problems than this if this job
does not work out so you know so he was
completely gay and until we moved out
here and we lived in Oak Creek
Apartments you know Oak Creek Apartments
and it's we had a two-bedroom apartment
and that second bedroom do any of you
know those apartments the second bedroom
is really small in fact the master
bedroom closet is bigger than the second
bedroom and our 13 year old lived in the
master bedroom closet for a year because
it was a bigger room and but I was our
10 year old in the second bedroom in our
teenager 13 year old in the master
bedroom closet so you know you just do
stuff and you know really it's just been
great fun I know a lot more about
medicine than I ever would have he knows
a lot more about business and we just
trained it off and you know you can't
ever look back and say what it could
have should've you know you just kind of
go and you always have to remember this
is a question we asked each other which
is what is the worst thing that can
happen okay it's like not that bad you
get another job and and so that sort of
sustained us but I have to say I mean
it's it was wild
there are many times where it was just
wild in terms of raising two teenagers
you know two boys tried to run you know
the neurosurgery career or a business
career I mean it was there were they
were there are always trade-offs here
and anyone who tells you that there are
not trade-offs is either superhuman
where they're not telling you the truth
you can decide which one how do you how
do you decide when you have Trados again
you try to do the most important thing
so what I concluded early on in my
career was that it was very difficult to
be the perfect wife the perfect mother
the perfect CEO the perfect hostess the
perfect charity person you cannot do
this and I decided you know long ago
that I would really focus on my job and
my family
and that I couldn't do a lot of these
other things you know my said this many
times my house does not look like Martha
Stewart just left I mean it's you know
everything's a trade-off if I could wear
a uniform to work every day I would um I
love Elizabeth Holmes do you know
Elizabeth home she was exact same thing
every single day I can completely relate
to that you know you've got ten black
turtlenecks ten black pants ten jet
black jackets can you just change them
out it's like brilliant I wish I'd
thought of it oh that's good fashion
advice so you know something has to give
here and and then we would just make the
decisions about what seemed to be the
most important and we did make a rule
that we tried one of us to be home every
night for dinner Monday through Thursday
and then we tried to all be home Friday
Saturday Sunday and and we would only do
things if the kids could come on the
weekends so you know you just make
trade-offs and you do the best you can
and there's there's no perfect there's
no perfect way to do it and I have many
friends who were in my class at Harvard
Business School in my class at Princeton
who decided to stay home full-time and
you know everyone has to make the
decision that you need to make that's
right for you and there's no textbook
there's no manual you just have to kind
of figure it out as you go along so it's
hard it's hard but very fun this would
be a good time to open up the floor to
questions from the audience on Twitter
we have two mics on this side and
Michelle on the other if you have a
question please raise your hand and keep
your hands raised so that they can spot
you you can also tweet your questions
usually using hashtag GSB VFD T
especially if you're up there and
Caroline up front would ask those
questions for you let's actually start
with a question from Twitter so Meg you
are often viewed as a trailblazer for
women in leadership is it more difficult
to be a woman in business and technology
or a woman
running for political office I would say
Roman Roman for political office it is
very very difficult and I'll tell you
why and I as you know I'm a Republican
but I have to happen to actually have a
lot of regard for what Hillary Clinton
has accomplished
because in business here's the grilling
good news about business there are
results okay every quarter you're
gaining a losing market share you have a
return on invested capital your sales
are growing there is a there's something
that you can anchor on in politics when
you're running and frankly even when
you're a politician the results are much
less clear so I think it's easier for
women and minorities and everyone when
there are results that you can point to
so I have to hand it to the women who
are in politics because the results are
not as clear and so therefore there can
be the politics there can be the
journalism or the reporters of opinion
you know there's just it's not as clear
and so I think that makes it much more
difficult because actually in some ways
I serve at the pleasure of the hill at
Packard board and that board evaluates
me based on the results you know I can a
purple hair and do whatever but the
results are the results and so that's
why I think it's a bit more difficult as
I you know sort of look at the landscape
which is why I think you know you've got
it you've got to actually hand it to a
lot of these women in politics who've
done really a remarkable job whether
it's you know members of Congress here
like you know zoloft grin or others
they've really done a great job take a
question there hi this is Sam from MSX
program you had a chance to go back to
like ten years ago what do you have done
differently in competition with Baba
so um I have the scars on my back from
two real challenges first let me start
with Japan because eBay is not number
one in Japan yahoo
auctions is number one in Japan and the
reason is is we have this very well
publicized outage in as I said June of
1999 and we were all set to launch in
Japan but then when the site crash we
actually had to fix the United States
and we were late launching to Japan and
in many businesses like eBay like PayPal
I would argue like uber like many of
these are what's called Network effects
that the more buyers you have the more
sellers you have and so the first market
often gets those Network effects and
Yahoo beat us to Japan because we had
technology issues
so if I had to do that over again I
would nail these technology issues much
faster than we did the second is China
and we bought a company in China called
each net the good news for eBay was
students like you when everyone saw
eBay's trajectory a lot of Stanford
Business School students and Harvard
Business School students went home to
their home country and started eBay
look-alikes and actually as an aside a
very funny story was Dan in Latin
America there was a Harvard Business
School group pitted against a Stanford
Business School group the Harvard
Business School company was dinner
Monday and the Stanford Business School
student was Mikado he braked
and we went down to figure out who to
partner with because we had an asset in
that we'd acquired through an
acquisition in Brazil or Argentina that
we wanted to trade for an equity stake
in the company and the Harvard Business
School students said absolutely not we
got this nailed we don't need you I pay
the Stanford students were like where do
we sign and today as you know that the
Stanford Business School students just
killed the Harvard Business School
students just over which was hurtful to
me but anyway the Stanford Business
School students totally nailed it and
and so then we bought a company called
each net and we made one big mistake
which is we should have left the each
net platform on their own platform in
China instead what we did is we put each
net onto the global eBay platform
because it had worked everywhere it had
worked in Western Europe it had worked
all of it we'd bought all these baby
eBay's and basically migrated them to
one common platform which had a lot of
advantages one is cost second is speed
to market because when you roll by it
now you could roll it to 30 countries as
opposed to do it incrementally but we
made a mistake in China as we moved each
net to the eBay platform and China is
different and about the same time
Alibaba ran into trouble because of the
SAR virus and so they focused on Taobao
and they had a uniquely Chinese platform
and by the way they didn't charge
anything for years and years and years
and years and they just out executed us
and so you know what I would have done
is
actually left bow Shou in charge and
owned the 30% of China that we also that
we originally owned and let him do his
own thing so that's really the lesson
there and you know we we have a PayPal
business there but the China business is
miniscule so you know what if you look
at Japan and China two important markets
it's where we didn't didn't
strategically actually do the right
thing but it was not obvious at the time
honestly so more power to Jack Ma what a
remarkable franchise he has built and it
is really in some way the combination of
course of PayPal of eBay
of Amazon I mean it's he's done a
remarkable remarkable job why do we have
high when you spoke about turning things
around at HP you spoke about returning
to the founders DNA and focusing on
innovation what changes did you make to
the company internally to really foster
that innovation and be conducive to the
employees taking charge so first of all
we laid out the strategy really really
quickly and we basically said these are
the things we're going to do well we're
going to make hard to do this but we're
going to do these things really well so
the first thing we did was actually
increase R&D spending while we were
reducing the cost structure of the
company dramatically I mean for those of
you who don't know we are down net
55,000 people at HP from the fall of
2012 so while we were doing that we're
actually increasing our investment in
R&D and that was hard to do right
because you've got to save so that you
can invest in what actually matters so
that was a really important thing
the second was reimagine the culture of
this company so many of you probably
know about the HP way this was the
original sort of codification of what
the culture was at HP founded by Bill
Hewlett and Dave Packard they were all
over this HP way and we knew we had to
reboot the culture but we didn't want to
throw out what made this company great
so we rebooted it we called it the HP
way now because you can never go back
you have to reinvent for the future but
we knew we had to take the threads of
what it made this company great so we
rolled that out across the entire
company and the second thing is we
aligned the financial
incentives to the strategy as it turns
out and you all know this but
particularly at big companies people
actually focus on what they're being
paid to do and you can wish it wasn't
that way you can wish a lot of things
but one of the things we did is we
compensated the top couple hundred
people on cash flow and we generated
remarkable cash flow at this company in
fact the repair of the balance sheet is
sort of amazing we went from about
eleven point nine billion dollars of net
debt on the operating company to five
point nine billion dollars of net cash
in three years that allowed us to get on
the front foot to be able to buy Aruba
to be able to buy voltage and you'll see
us do a lot more acquisitions because we
have the balance sheet to do it and so
had we not focused on cash flow and had
we not paid the people who really had an
influence on cash flow because as you
know cash conversion cycle as day sales
outstanding days payable and inventory
and it was just amazing to watch this
battleship turn and frankly that's a lot
of the reason that our stock went from
eleven dollars and sixty-two cents or
whatever the low was to close to forty
over Christmas now we have a different
challenge which is foreign exchange
which is a problem that every other big
American company has not just in our
industry but you've just got to focus on
what are the most important things and
how do you incentivize that so I would
say increasing R&D spending focusing R&D
spending celebrating the engineers
celebrating innovation pivoting back to
the customers and the channels and then
you know focusing on the things that
will make the biggest difference from
the financial perspective because
there's a sort of an interesting
flywheel here which is if you can
improve the results remember back to
what I said to the other woman about
results actually matter if you can
improve the results that gives customers
employees and the street confidence
which enables you to sell more which
enables you to do better which starts
this positive flywheel going which
allows you to and by the way the sort of
external view of how well you're doing
is the stock price so going from 11 or
12 dollars to close to 40 made a big
difference in sort of the esprit de
corps we created 40 billion dollars of
market
okay so we created Twitter LinkedIn
maybe we created one of these in the
last three years here and that gave
people a lot of confidence including by
the way our partners and our customers
Kalin do we have a question from Twitter
so mag another question from Twitter
you've talked about reviving innovation
and suggested that many alumni and
people in this audience join startups
how can startups actually collaborate
with HP avowedly so we've just launched
a program that we call Pathfinder which
is how do we reach out into the valley
to find the new startups that are
complementary to what we're either HP
Inc is going or Hill at Packard
Enterprise is going and how do we either
create you know an investment
opportunity that would be good for
startups or the thing that HP does
really well is our go-to-market I
mentioned we sell through 150,000 VARs
we're in 170 countries and we have a
direct selling force that is actually
second to none so what we're now trying
to do is reach out into the valley
because we're here and now we're healthy
enough to do it to make sure that we've
got the right relationships with the
venture community and with startups so
to the extent there are startups that
are enterprise focused on the Hewlett
Packard Enterprise side or 3d printing
focused on the on the other side how do
we make the investments and then decide
when it might be the right thing to open
our go-to-market
now we can't go to market with lots and
lots of startups you know we've got a
huge portfolio we've got to sell but
every once in a while we can make a bet
on a startup that enables them to be
part of a solution that we sell and
allows the startup to take advantage of
our go-to-market so that's the way we're
thinking about it and for the first
couple of years there's when you do a
turnaround there is pacing and
sequencing there is only so much a
company can do even a company as big as
HP if you do not focus on the small
number of things that matter you are not
going to turn your your enterprise
around and so wow this was something I
wanted to do when I first got here it
was literally all hands on deck
on a small number of things to make sure
that we got the turnaround under way so
those that's you know that's how we're
sort of hoping we're going to tap into
this ecosystem and ultimately they're
you know we as I said we have got to
acquire more innovation than we do today
listen organic innovation will always be
number one but we have to be more
acquisitive I think as a technology
company in one of the greatest
technology dislocations I've seen in my
career
I shall get it ingress Meg thank you for
your time my name is Kristen I'm a
second year MBA student here earlier you
talked about give an example about how
one can do to lose hearts and minds I
was wondering can you talk about how one
can do to win hearts and minds
specifically do you think the purchase
need to be different when you starting
out your career post MBA as a junior
person versus someone in the senior
position thank you so it's a very good
question um so listen I think how you
win hearts and minds and how you become
a trusted colleague is the same when
you're the CEO is when you're a new
person and that is do what you say
you're going to do and one of the very
first things I said I was going to do at
HP was I was going to figure out whether
we should sell this PC Group and we're
going to do it in 30 days and I did and
so there was very early on it was here's
set him up knock him down and I my
advice to all of you is say what you're
going to do if you join a startup or you
join an established company say what you
mean mean what you say and get it done
without a lot of stuff and so that's the
first thing the second is and this alert
from politics when you are trying to win
hearts and minds of a big company like
HP there's something unlearned in
politics and that is called symbolic
value so you might remember when Jerry
Brown won the election he did something
actually that at first I thought was not
very smart and then I thought it was
genius
you might recall he decided to take away
cell phones from about half the civil
servants in the in the name of narrowing
the budget gap in the state of
California okay the intellectual the
left-brain meg said that is the dumbest
thing I've ever seen
the cell phone budget for the state of
California is 0.001 percent and will not
make a difference but actually what he
was commuted
getting to the electorate is I'm on it
and if you had asked a citizen in the
state of California when he did that
they would have said jarred brownies on
this cost thing he is taking cell phones
away from the civil servants one could
argue you should have unplugged the
landlines but doesn't matter the point
was he had a lot of symbolic value watch
politicians so much of what they do is
symbolic value the State of the Union
address the guests that the president
has in the gallery is all symbolic value
so I learnt that so when it came to HP I
said what is the thing that we can do
that will show the company that this is
going to be different and the very first
thing we did is tore down the executive
parking lot with the commando fence and
the barbed wire around it and everyone
walks in the front door just like
everyone else
the second thing we did is I tore out
all the wood paneled offices in the
executive area of HP and we all sit in
cubicles just like every other cubicle
worldwide in HP and we never actually
had to publicize this 330,000 HP people
knew this within about thirty two and a
half seconds and so it's not substantial
ok ripping out the cubicle or ripping
out the wood paneled office didn't
actually do anything it just showed the
kind of company that we wanted to run
and so this symbolic values I think are
really really important now it does not
substitute for delivering the results
but you're trying to win hearts and
minds fast you're trying to show that
this is a different thing
and results take a while to turn right
so you've got to sort of say hey here's
the kind of company that we want to be
and celebrating some of the early
innovation one of my executives when I
got there had actually gone out to HP
labs and said what do you got and we
found some incredible things in HP Labs
we celebrated those and we brought them
to market really fast so the other thing
I would advise when you are running a
company or doing a turnaround is early
wins
so when eBay bought PayPal PayPal was
not entirely thrilled to be bought by
eBay back in the day and so what we did
is we immediately integrated the PayPal
functionality into the largest
marketplace in the world and what
happened of course is PayPal volume went
through the roof and so the PayPal
people said wow this is furthering our
mission
this is making PayPal more successful
being part of eBay is making my job more
fun making the company more successful
so that early win is really really
important and we're running that play
again with a ribeye so how do we make
sure that the aruba team who is actually
quite thrilled to be part of HP but how
do we get early wins for Aruba how does
the Aruba team feel and six months from
now
Wow being part of HP was fantastic for
us so that's the kind of thing that you
think about I'm going to be selfish yes
slip in a last question sure
this question has become a more recent
view from the top tradition and every
ethnic inter Stanford GSB is asked to
fill an answer for this question their
essays so here is it what matters most
to you and why yeah so listening I bet
there's a hundred answers to this
question but in the end the thing that
matters most to me and if you think
about it I bet matters most to you which
is your family and your extended network
of friends in the end that is super
important so while we get wrapped around
the axle of doing whatever we're doing
it is really important to remember that
that's what matters most I'll say the
other thing is perspective and this has
been one of the delights of being
married to a neurosurgeon okay what we
do in business is important it's
incredibly important it's important to
the employees of HP to our VARs but no
one gets hurt at HP no one dies and so
remembering what's really important is I
think critical and I'll tell you a
little story which I've told on a number
of occasions so one of my closest
friends from Harvard Business School who
was in my section had a great career in
Los Angeles and has two children who are
about the same age as my children and
her 24 year old went into the green
berets and was killed in Afghanistan in
June so when things seem pretty tough
remember your 24 year old did not get
killed in Afghanistan so I think you've
just got to remember what actually
matters here and it's great to be
wrapped up in work it is terrific but in
the end that is the perspective of what
is really really important here
honestly and I will say when I lost the
governor's race it was hard to have that
perspective because it's what it could
have should have if I'd done this if I'd
done that you know maybe it would have
turned out differently in the end
nothing really bad happened I lost the
governor's race and you in you know my
family was intact my husband was a
menial you just have to remember and
then last but not least I would say your
reputation you have to be known as high
integrity doing what you say saying what
you mean because everything can go away
and if you still have your integrity
intact and so often an eBay of HP you
know I often ask what is the right thing
to do here and it's challenging because
the right thing to do is quite different
in different cultures and I always used
to say to our teams it may be different
in different countries but if your
mother or your father or someone you
love your children were reading the New
York Times and they knew what you were
doing
would they be proud or if they were
sitting in the eve of the conference
room watching the decision-making
process would they be proud of you and
that's the ultimate question whether
you're you know from Asia or from Latin
America or for Europe usually having
that notion of what would your parents
think transverses all those cultural
norms about what's acceptable and what's
not so I think those are those are the
three things that I'd point to right
away thank you so much from you